So Leute, jetzt bin ich aber start.
Sagen wir mal, hat irgendjemand von euch eine Ahnung, wie man, bitte her, ich höre mich,
ach ich hab meinen Vorschau nicht gemutet, mega null, erst war es gleich da, kann ich
wegmachen, hat irgendjemand von euch eine Ahnung, wie ich einen PS4 oder einen PSN-Account resetten
kann, der nur als Recovery-Option bei Sony nur das Geburtstag eingetragen hat und ich
weiß den Geburtstag nicht mehr, das ist mein Problem, mein alter Account, den ich jahrelang
auf der PS3 verwendet hab, den wollte ich recovern und ich kam mir nicht mehr mit einloggen,
den wollte ich recovern und es funktioniert einfach nicht und ich weiß das Geburtstag
nicht mehr, no happy meal for you, dankeschön, Alper, es, wobei, warum hab ich denn da keine
transparente Version, von was ist das denn, was ist das, TOS, Anzeige ist raus, übrigens,
ich hab jetzt, ich sollte jetzt eigentlich zwei Emotes haben, wenn sie das zweite schon
freigeschaltet haben, wir haben LUL, wir haben WUB-LUL, haben wir und wir haben WUB-S, oh
ne, haben sie nicht freigeschaltet, WUB-S ist der, ist der Monka-Smoke, Monka-Smoke
ist WUB-S, der hier, aber den gibt's nicht mehr, äh den gibt's noch nicht, X-Shadow-Ghost,
weiter Monat in Folge, BigBrain-Subscriber, oh, der ist abgehackt, das ist jetzt, äh 4.5
hat, da fehlt was, sollten wir, vor einer halben hat, er ist abgehackt, ich bin abgehackt,
ja, ich hab was rausgekriegt, also hat keiner von euch ne Ahnung, wie das mit dem Playstation
Account ist oder, hat Sony irgendwie ne Hotline, die man anrufen kann, weiß das jemand, ich
hab halt das Problem, ich hätte gerne meinen alten Account Vita, ich weiß aber am besten
Willen nicht mehr, was ich da für nen Geburtstag eingetragen hab, also mein echter Geburtstag
ist es auf jeden Fall nicht, das hab ich ausprobiert, aber das hat nicht funktioniert, ich trage
auch nirgendswo meinen echten Geburtstag ein, 2 Monate, Lulz, ja, Martin, nice, BigBrain,
also halb BigBrain, da fehlt heute die Hälfte, eher der hier, Subscriber, ist es Prime, ist
es Prime, du musst dort anrufen, die haben eine Hotline bis um 6 glaube ich, die sind
aber super unkooperativ, ja die Sache ist, ich kanns halt auch gar nicht wirklich beweisen,
das einzige was ich beweisen kann bei dem Account ist, dass ich Zugang zu der E-Mail Adresse
hab mit dem der Account registriert ist, oh ja heute ist richtig hot, heute ist richtig
hot, ist der Chat heute eigentlich cute, cute Chat, oder ist heute Hate Speech Chat, Point
Forest Jump, der Sebaro ist da, stimmt, wenn der Sebaro da ist, ich bin grad kurz vorm
Abkratzen, brauch KS, so ey, das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss, tschüss,
ey jetzt gehts, ich glaube du musst bloß Zugang zu E-Mail haben, die wollen dann aber
ein neues Geburtsdatum, gegebenenfalls mit Personalausweis, das Problem bei dem Account
ist, ich vermute mal, ich kenn mich ja, ich vermute mal, dass ich dort eingetragen hab,
ich heiße Max Bloop Bloop Bloop oder so und ein Geburtsdatum was nicht stimmt, das heißt
ich kann den weder einen Ausweis zeigen, noch irgendwas, aber was ich ihnen zeigen kann
ist, dass ich den Account in alten Videos verwende, die Videos sind 6 Jahre alt, wenn
du da anrufst wäre es gut die letzten 3 Käufe für den ACC zu wenden, die letzten 3 Käufe,
das weiß ich, das ist einfach, Playstation Plus, Uncharted, also diese Spin-Off Uncharted
und wahrscheinlich nochmal Playstation Plus oder sowas, die wollen einen Ausweis für
ein neues Geburtsdatum, achso, ich will den auch, warum braucht jeder Depp heutzutage
mein Ausweis, mein Geburtsdatum, ich will doch nur den Graben spielen, das ist doch keine
Partnervermittlung, wooblull, ja ich bin 11, ich weiß, 12 und Mercy Main, sag mal, der
Upload spackt, Leute, der Upload spackt, der Stream ruckelt, ne, der Upload spackt, was
ist mit Unity Media, los, ok, los, ne, mein OBS lose frames, das ist schlecht, warte mal
Leute, ich muss das glaube ich mal kurz umstellen, warum lose mein OBS frames, frame loss ist
ein ziemlicher Sack, kann man das live anpassen, während man online ist, die frame rate, die
bitrate, geht das, nein, leider nicht, fuck, oder, hat er es jetzt gecheckt, jetzt ist gut
glaube ich, jetzt glaube ich kein frame loss mehr, also Leute, ich fange jetzt mal an zu
spielen, wir probieren das jetzt mal aus, wenn frame loss ist, ich mache erstmal die
Musik aus, wenn frame loss ist, dann müsst ihr mir das im Chat sagen, das sieht immer
unscharf aus, also wenn wir frame loss haben, müsst ihr mir das sagen, weil ich hab ja,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich erzähle, ich hab mir meinen Telekom Anschluss abbestellt,
ich bin jetzt komplett über Unity Media drinne und Unity Media hat noch nicht, ne, ne, ne,
das liegt nicht an Nutschdreck, das ist Upload, ich hab die bitrate hochgestellt auf 5 MBit,
sag ich kein Problem, ich hab bei Unity Media aktuell 6 MBit, als nächstes, also demnächst
in ein paar Tagen hab ich 40, aber aktuell hab ich halt bloß 6 MBit und irgendwie spackt
der rum, weiß nicht, ich hab jetzt mal auf 4,5 MBit runtergestellt, in der Hoffnung,
ich hab keine frame losses, die Sache ist die, ich hab aber halt keine Ahnung, ob das
von der Bandbreite für das Game reicht, naja, wir werden sehen, ich stöpsel jetzt um und
wir spielen ne Runde, achso, ich muss mich noch verzögern, Verzögerung einstellen,
500 Millisekunden Verzögerung, weil sonst passt mein Gelaber nicht zu dem, was man sieht
auf dem Bildschirm, ich mach die bitrate noch mal nen Ticken runter, ich mach noch mal kurz
hier Output, ich mach mal runter, na gut, 4,5 ist eigentlich gut, ich mein 0,5 reicht dicke
für nen Game, Pogas, ich bin froh, wenn ich 40 MBit Upload hab, ich hatte bei der Telekom
VDSL mit 40 up, 100 down, die Sache war plus die, das Ding war so instabil, ich stöpsel
mal in der Zwischenzeit den Kram hier an die Playstation um, das war so instabil der Kram,
dass es sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt hat das zu haben und dementsprechend hab ich gesagt,
ok bevor ich zwei Internetanschlüsse bezahle, dann fliegt die Telekom weg, Telekom fliegt
raus und eigentlich sollten wir jetzt Menümusik haben oder, sollten wir jetzt nicht Menümusik
haben, ok was auch immer, so ich stelle mal den Monitor um, erstmal schon mal Game suchen,
rumschalten, Monitor, so, hallo Monitor, ok zumindest, das Problem ist, dass halt Unity
Media erst, die brauchen bisschen, also ich hab jetzt abgecreated auf, oh wie heißt der
Kram, auch keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, die Tarife da blick ich nicht durch, Telekom
ist bei mir extrem, also viel, viel instabiler gewesen als Unity Media, Unity Media hat einen
schlechteren Ruf, ich hab ja auch mal ein Video gemacht, wie kacke ich Unity Media finde,
das ist im Prinzip ist das immer noch so, was die da treiben, ja, aber es ist auch immer
ein bisschen regional abhängig ja und anscheinend ist es bei mir halt so, dass es voll für
Arsch ist, ok wo gehen wir denn jetzt lang, erstmal einspielen, der Typ ist in der Mitte,
Psst.
Easy Win, schon auf der Flagge gecampt, schon auf der Flagge gecampt, dann ist mein Typ
aber afk, ich glaub mein Dude ist afk, der Typ ist afk, mein Teamate ist afk, was ist
das, das ist ja mal wieder geiler, Alter, das Ibaro, der hat gefallen an, an, an, an,
wo blodeln, wie es aussieht, der ist afk, das können wir nicht gewinnen, ok, äh, Moment,
warum konnte der, warum konnte der Typ so schnell schießen, ah, wir haben noch das Secondary,
huge brainer, wenn ich Secondary hab ich hier gar nicht gedacht, oh fuck, ok, ok, ok, ok,
das kannst du nicht gewinnen, das kannst du nicht gewinnen mit einem afk Teamate, was
ist das, sagt ok, wir gehen uns mir, wir müssen es jetzt alleine reißen, oh nee, jetzt
kommt auch die Shotgun Runde, ok, wir müssen jetzt Risiko gehen, ja, what, what, warum darf
der, warum darf der Typ mich one shotten, ich hier nicht, wo blodeln, was ist das, afk
ja, dude, ist natürlich auch geil, Kotlogik, das ist mega Kotlogik, tsch, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ability, ok, ok, ok.
Ich bin schon volle Pulle da hingerannt.
Kannste nicht gewinnen alleine, wie soll das funktionieren?
Das sackt mega, wenn du alleine spielst. Warum joint man ein Game und geht dann AFK?
Warum geht man einfach in AFK? Verstehe ich nicht. Quitt doch einfach was.
Okay, 50 mal hitten.
Meine Güte, wie soll man das alleine gewinnen?
Der Laser, ja man sieht die Laser, wenn das eine Laserwaffe ist.
Kann man auch Splitscreen spielen? Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Also zumindest nicht auf der alten Playstation, auf der Pro vielleicht.
Weil selbst wenn das geht auf der alten, also die Performance ist grottenschlecht auf der nicht Pro Playstation.
Man hat eine niedrigere Auflösung, was bei Long Range, also wenn du vom Spawn aus irgendwie schießt mit einer M14 oder sowas, ist es ein riesen Unterschied.
Man hat mit der niedrigeren Auflösung richtige Probleme die Gegner teilweise zu sehen und zu hitten und die treffen halt bei einem den Finger.
Also in dem Spiel lohnt es sich massiv eine PS Pro zu haben.
Mittlerweile finde ich die Map übrigens hier ganz nice.
Jetzt so bevorzugend wie eigentlich die Playstation 4. Naja, ist einfach.
Wo ist Nachlein? Der andere kommt gleich von links. Oder auch nicht.
Wo? What? Okay von wo? Von wo? Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Okay.
Der eine steht noch im Spawn. Jetzt war mal Trick 17 Leute.
Nein, du musst nicht preordert haben. Danke schön für den Prime.
Leute, ich sehe wieder nicht, weil ich keine Vorschau hier gescheit habe in Game, ob einer gesagt hat oder nicht.
Danke an alle, die es haben. Ich versuche es mitzukriegen. Wenn ich es nicht mitkriege, spammt mich einfach voll.
Man sieht hier so schlecht die Gegner.
Auf zu schnaufen.
Warum soll ich rauslaufen, wenn ich mehr Leben habe?
Es ist so schlimm. Es ist übelsreudig, wenn man jemanden hat, der einfach reincharged.
Wenn die Gegner halbwegs gescheit spielen, kannst du alleine nichts machen.
Das ist der beste.
Schreckt.
Sound beste.
Okay, wir machen Yolo Aktion.
Nop, keine Chance.
Der andere Typ ist instand Down. Immer. Achne, der lebt noch.
Du Kumpel links, links, links, links, links, links, links, rechts, rechts, links, links, links.
Oh Gott.
Oh Alter.
Wenn ich mir das angucke.
Wie der Claymore, wie der Claymore vor sich setzt, Alter, what the fuck, was ist das, bitte schon wieder, was soll das Teufel, was soll ich denn machen?
Na, der hat mich geherrt, Charlotte, bist du down?
Das ist, die Waffe ist übelst nice, also wenn du damit gut triffst, ist schreckt.
Ist Glorsplay schon Alpha? Nee.
Nope. Okay, wir müssen wieder Yoloen.
Ha! Bam!
Scheiße! So muss das sein. 8406.
Oh nee, fuck, ich hab keine Granate, ich hab die Spritze.
Okay, okay, ah gut, nicht getroffen.
Schmeißt deinen Job und bewirbt dich bei Optik, ich sag doch nicht Optik, Face, Alter, Face.
Oh, hat nen Kill gemacht, mein Dude hat nen Kill gemacht, perfekt. Mit diesen Waffen hat man wirklich nen richtigen Vorteil mit der Pro.
Sag mal, spielst du mit Controller? Nein, spiel ich mit Controller?
Warum soll ich freiwillig mit Controller spielen? Ich hab gestern mit Controller gespielt, das ging mir richtig auf den Keks.
Was hast du für eine Ingame-Auflösung? Da kannst du ja nicht einstellen. Ich hatte heute Morgen im Hauptmenü eingestellt 720p.
Das Problem ist nur, dass das Spiel läuft dann flüssiger auf normalen PS4. Die Sache ist nur, dass es die Auflösung noch weiter runterschraubt, dass man die Gegner noch schlechter sieht.
Ich hab jetzt wieder hochgestellt auf 1080p im Menü. Das unterstützt Tastatur und Maus, ja guck hier, Maus.
Ich wusste das gestern auch nicht, hätt ich das gestern schon gewusst.
Es ruckelt eigentlich, oder ist es okay? Ich glaub es müsste okay sein, jetzt wo ich die Auflösung runtergestellt hab.
Sehen wir es okay.
Wir gehen jetzt links. Wir warten jetzt hier bis die Stun-Ready ist.
Nice. Weißt du, wenn man ein gutes Team hat, ist das gut. Der checkt auch wo die Gegner sind und der war ja schon übelst gehitted.
Manche Pistolen fühlen sich richtig mies an. Die Desert Eagle ist richtig geil, aber diese Dinger, ich mein vier Hits auf den Gegner für nix.
Aber wir warten bis die Flash-Ready ist.
Komm her. Wir gewinnen, wir müssen überhaupt nichts machen.
Er darf bloß das Ding nicht captchern.
Gut das, wenn wir mehr Leben hatten. Man gewinnt, wenn man mehr lebt.
Auch wie das ruckelt auf der normalen PS, das ist so fail.
Als Treffen kann man nicht, 0-1.
Erstmal gucken, wo die hinstelzen.
Was? Ich war geflasht. Ich sehe die Typen halt nicht.
Jetzt haben wir unsere geile Schneiber.
Ich sehe die Dudes nicht.
Besser mit dem Control kannst du knicken.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt mal ein bisschen was machen.
Oben in der Mitte.
Wo? Ich sehe die ums verrecken.
Ich würde gerne den Kill sehen. Habt ihr den Gegner gesehen?
Okay.
Wir kriegen so heftig auf die Fresse.
Schloss.
Gott in der Nutschel, ja das ist echt so.
1,5, bäh.
Komische Shotgun, was haben wir denn als Secondary?
Wow, ist gut, Alter, ist gut.
Wo?
Easy, okay, spielst du noch Overwatch?
Nee, gerade nicht mehr.
Ich hab's mal wieder versucht, jetzt wo Role-Q da ist.
Mit Role-Q hab ich's wieder mal probiert, aber irgendwie ist die Luft raus bei Overwatch.
Wenigstens habe ich jetzt mal einen Typ dabei, der mich carried.
So auch mal was.
Das gibt's nicht. Ich krieg echt die Krise.
Warum killt das den jetzt nicht beim Nahkampf?
Fuck, Alter.
Dabei haben wir richtig gut umlaufen und dann zack.
Am Arsch.
1-7.
Da muss ich mal den Titel ändern.
Das Bambi fehlt, ja.
Oh, 5-5.
Er so ruckelt.
Kollege, mach ihn blatt. Please. Mach ihn blatt.
Er hat nicht mehr viel.
Bleib einfach, hide. Hide, hide, hide.
Nice.
Er konnte immer viel haben.
Okay, 1-8.
Fuck, jetzt kann ich mal den angucken.
Geh weg.
Next is game.
Ich glaube, ich verzogen beim ersten Shot.
Ich meine, Shotgun mit zwei Schuss sollte ja das Potential haben,
wenn man quasi an dem Gegner dran steht, ihn trotzdem zu one-shotten.
Das war übrigens in Black Ops 1 mein Lieblingsshotgun, der war mega geil.
Und dem ganzen Maus und Tastatur besser.
Ja, aber die Auflösung von einer normalen PS4 ist scheiße.
Ich habe übelste Probleme, die Gegner zu sehen.
Und es ruckelt.
Und die Maus, ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob man es jetzt im Menü sieht,
was für eine Abtast-Range ist.
Was für eine Abtastrate die Maus hier an der PS4 hat.
Also flüssig ist das nicht, wie das Ding hier über den Bildschirm wandert.
Ja, habt ihr, habt ihr glaube ich gerade...
Die neue Map, die gab es gestern nicht, die haben sie gestern reingepatcht.
Also eine Sache, die ich rausgekriegt habe, das ist immer nice,
wenn dieser Warlock am Anfang an ist, guckt man hier so in die Richtung.
So hier, dann denken die alle, man rennt hier lang.
Dann denken alle, man rennt hier lang.
Und dann rennt man da lang.
Big brain.
Ich kann mich nicht bewegen.
Ich kann mich nicht bewegen, äh, wenn du an der Wand legst.
Hielt man nicht, nein, nein, in dem Modus halt man nicht.
In dem Modus halt man nicht.
Es sei denn, man hat so eine Spritze als Perk,
aber das ist random, was man für eine Perk kriegt.
Kann man hier lang?
Okay.
Die, die, das sind Deaths, die würde ich gerne sehen.
Halt, ich frag mich immer so, man ist auf gleicher Range,
schießt sich mit der Shotgun gleichermaßen an,
aber man ist one hand oder andere nicht.
Okay, nice.
So geht's, du bist auch okay.
Also du kannst dich nur heilen, wenn du gespritzt,
wenn du die Spritze als Perk hast, aber die Perk spawnen random.
Oder zumindest spawnen die Perks oder die Waffen nach einem hier nicht erkennbaren Muster.
Huge aim.
Mein Team-Mail macht das.
Was aber was übel Spaß macht an dem Modus ist,
dass es nicht wie in Call of Duty normalerweise,
dass wenn man Treffer macht, dass es nichts bringt,
wenn die Gegner zwei Sekunden später halt wieder geheilt sind.
Achtung, YOLO, YOLO-Charge.
Ah, meine Güte ey.
Das ist, das ist Closed, PS4, Exklusiv, Alpha.
Wow, aber was ist das?
PS4, Exklusiv, Alpha.
Wow, aber mein Team-Mail, der will es wissen.
Das ist immer schwierig, wenn du auf offener Fläche stehst,
der Gegner links oder rechts raus kann.
Übrigens wisst ihr, weil ich noch gar nicht gecheckt habe,
wie man diese, diese Sachen sich mountet an die...
What the fuck?
Ha, wusste ich doch, dass der von rechts kommt.
Ja, das ist PS4.
Man kann die Alpha mit Tastatur und Maus stehlen.
Man wird das auch beim Release können,
allerdings kommt man dann halt mit PC-Leuten zusammen.
Wir machen das jetzt wieder so.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Wir warten jetzt.
Ha, erwischt.
Rausgenadet.
Pock.
Warte, warte, warte, warte.
Ich will die naden da hinten.
Der steht wieder hinter seinem Kack.
Komm her.
Fuck.
Outplayed, würde ich sagen.
Huge outplayed.
Ich finde es auf DOC lohnt sich das richtig, wenn man kurz wartet.
Achtung.
Der war da oben, ich hab ihn gesehen.
Boah, was das?
What?
Ich war doch schon längst um die Ecke, ich hab den gesehen.
Fuck, Alter.
Welche Maus Tastatur benutzt du?
Quasar K95 und eine G403.
Scheiße.
Es ist halt kacke, wenn man down ist mit Helft.
Was willst du machen?
Waren wir überhaupt mit Helft down?
Ich glaub schon.
Komm jetzt Leute.
Ja.
Wenn man weiß wo der Gegner ist, dann klappt das.
Dann läufts.
Ich hab immer die gleichen Leute am PC gefunden.
PC ist halt, also es macht halt mehr Bock.
Also für mich auf dem PC in ordentlicher Auflösung mit Außen Tastatur zu spielen.
Aber was die Spielerbasis angeht ist Call of Duty auf der Konsole halt meilenweit voraus.
Das muss man einfach einsehen.
Das ist halt so.
Der neue Modus ist übrigens ganz merkwürdig.
Das ist das gleiche, bloß dass man Waffen aufheben muss.
Was kann man alles in der Alpha spielen?
Naja, nur das hier.
Nur das hier auf vier verschiedenen Maps.
Es gibt Pine, es gibt die Map, es gibt diese Ball, irgendwas mit Ball.
Dann gibt es die, schwierig zu beschreiben diese Maps.
Die sehen alle irgendwie ziemlich uninspiriert aus.
Box haben wir eben gesehen, Pine und dann die anderen Stadtmaps oder was das, ne nicht Stadtmaps, Müll, Müllplatzmaps.
Jawoll.
Also es hält sich in Grenzen ja.
Und die Map mag ich mit Abstand am wenigsten.
Die Alpha geht glaube bis morgen, bis morgen oder bis Montag, nicht lang.
Das muss man.
Also eins habe ich gecheckt schon, wenn man mit anonymen Leuten spielt, auch nicht im Voice Chat,
man muss gucken, wenn der pusht, du musst mitpushen, wenn du nicht mitpushst, bist du voll im Arsch.
Weggeschnipsert.
Was du liest, nur dass es auf einer PS4 eine Alpha gibt, ja.
Wobei man immer sagen muss, ja Alpha, Beta, das ist bei Call of Duty so ein dehnbarer Begriff.
Also es ist im Prinzip eine Demo, wenn man so will, eine eingeschränkte Demo.
Was?
Bin ich blind?
Jetzt sagt der Chat gleich ja, ich weiß es genau.
Das war doch drauf, er zählt mir nichts Leute.
Ach okay, das ist wieder gelieft, ja gut.
Hey, ist wieder gelieft.
Was willst du machen?
Ich frage mich, falls sie sowas wie einen Rank Modus machen, falls.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es dazu Infos gibt.
Falls sie sowas machen, dann hoffe ich, dass es mehr zur Auswahl gibt als nur den Modus.
Das wäre nice.
Ja, es werden auch alle mit Tastatur und Maus in eigene Lobbys kommen.
Also Crossplay, so wie ich das verstanden habe, funktioniert nur mit Maus.
Also wenn du am PC mit Gamepad spielst, wirst du wohl gematcht mit Gamepad.
Und wenn du mit Maus Tastatur spielst, wirst du gematcht mit Maus Tastatur.
Und man kann wohl angeblich mal gucken, wie das dann wirklich ist, wenn das Game rauskommt.
Entweder muss man Crossplay aktivieren oder man muss Crossplay explizit deaktivieren.
Ich glaube mal eher, man muss Crossplay aktivieren.
Herr Kiyoko, ein extra für dich neuer Cute Emote.
Cute, tschatte.
Easy as fuck.
Okay, auf geht's.
Die Map gefällt mir persönlich eigentlich am besten.
Also Pine finde ich am nervigsten.
Die finde ich am besten.
Docs geht so und diese Schrottplatz Map ist...
Wobei die Maps sehen alle nach Schrottplatz aus.
Oh mein Gott.
Get the camera.
Nice one.
Slaversaver.
Ich fänd's gut, wenn die Maps machen würden, die nicht aussehen wie...
Wir nehmen im Map Editor einfach Kisten und Treppen und stellen sie hin.
Und wisst ihr was auch übelst freudig ist?
Dass man nix hört.
Dass man nix hört, wenn man gehittert wird, das ist übelst kacke.
Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp.
Was machen die Gegner denn bitteschön gerade?
Warte, willst du...
Die rennen jetzt schon ins Fahnenkreuz rein.
Die Alpha ist nur für die PS4, japp.
Richtig.
Ach, die sind gelieft.
Das ist PS4, ja?
Ja, das ist PS4.
Ach.
Du kannst mit Tastatur einen Maus spielen.
Fuck, das hab ich verkackt.
Das hab ich mega verschissen, ey.
Wo, blul.
Ich glaube, auf solche Entfernung ist es besser,
man schießt nicht mit Ironsight,
sondern man ballert aus der Hüfte.
Wir probieren jetzt mal was.
Okay, jetzt.
Ich find's immer geil, wie gut die mit Controller treffen, die Dudes.
Allerdings, muss man sagen,
Höherauflösung muss man sagen,
aber es ist ein bisschen schwer,
allerdings, muss man sagen,
Höherauflösung macht halt auch...
Höherauflösung macht halt auch übertrieben was aus.
Ich war schon kurz davor, mir eine PS4 Pro zu bestellen,
aber ich hab mir gedacht,
Max, Max, langsam, langsam, Max,
nicht übertreiben, weil du wirst das Game überhaupt nicht auf der PS4 spielen,
und nächstes Jahr kommt die PS5 drauf.
Und nächstes Jahr kommt die PS4 drauf.
Machste nix?
Wenn du gebashed wirst...
Der Typ weiß, wo ich bin.
Ich nicht.
What?
Wir haben gleichzeitig aufeinander geschossen.
Der hatte kein Leben mehr gehabt.
Okay, ich hab nur einen Schuss rausgekriegt.
Okay, ich hab nur einen Schuss rausgekriegt von angeblich 4.
Puh, äh...
Gott, easy clap, Eier, ja.
Ja, geht doch.
Oh nee, Shotgun-Runde, du.
Ah, shit. Dacht, ich hab den nicht gehört.
Das müssen die unbedingt ändern, dass man nichts mehr hört, wenn man gehitted wird.
Sobald du einmal gehitted wirst, kriegst du von der Welt nichts mit.
Oh, Kollege.
What?
Also manche Tote sind sehr komisch.
Früher waren auf der Xbox mehr Leute.
Also bald zu 360 Zeiten, ja.
Okay, wir kriegen auf die Fresse.
Okay, wir halten mal fest.
Zwei Schüsse aus der Shotgun und ein Pistolen-Schuss hat nicht gereicht, ihn zu köllen.
Und er schießt zweimal in meine Richtung, ich bin down.
Easy.
Next.
Moir, probier ich mal mit Leuten, mal mit jemanden zusammen zu spielen.
Muss mal gucken, entweder mit dem Anders Serial, der wollte ja gestern schon spielen.
Oder mal gucken, eigentlich wollte ich auch mal mit dem Shoxen-Runde spielen.
Das wird mit Sicherheit gleich deutlich besser laufen, wenn man mit Leuten kommunizieren kann.
Weil aktuell ist es halt übelst random.
Jaja, der lebt noch, der hat gestern sogar geschrieben.
Die Map mag ich, die Map mag ich.
Geht los mit Range-Singelschuss-Waffe, die aussieht wie eine Shotgun.
Außen-Keyboard funktioniert gut, du kannst direkt anschließen.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, wo er ist.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo er ist.
What the fuck ey, mein Gott, warum treff ich die nicht?
Okay, mein Dude macht das.
Easy win, jetzt rennt er ins Feuer.
Ich kann mit diesem Ding überhaupt nicht umgehen.
Ich schieß immer vorbei, immer, selbst mit Mausentastatur.
Rechts, rechts, rechts, irgendwo.
Ich glaub, der Typ ist an der Fahne.
Nee, links ist er.
Ah, schreckt.
Die Modes sind da, aber leider nur eins, das andere ist ja nicht genehmigt.
Jetzt, jetzt, huge plays, Leute.
Und wir haben ne Spritze, sehr gut.
Boca schwitzt so aus.
Manchmal bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig.
What?
Ach, mein Dude hat hinter mir gestanden, kann das sein?
Nee.
Wo ist denn mein Team-Mate gestorben?
Alleine, ach, deswegen krieg ich so krass auf die Fresse.
Ach gut, wenn ihr mir rein rennt, was soll ich dann machen?
Da geht ja sonst nichts.
Easy.
Nein, der Play war gut, der Play war gut.
Leider hat das Timing nicht gepasst.
Ich dachte mir, dass der da herkommt, die Sache ist plus die, man hört es natürlich nicht, weil man nichts hört, wenn man gehittert wird.
Okay, wir haben noch eine Chance.
Die time to kill, nee, die time to kill ist ziemlich gut.
Die time to kill finde ich diesmal ist genau richtig.
Nee, das ist PS4, ist das, PS4.
Piss, piss vor.
What? What?
Der Typ war eben rechts hinter mir, ihr habt es doch auch gehört, oder?
Wie ist der denn auf die andere Seite gekommen?
Also manchmal jebaitet der Sound, übelst krass.
Übelst hat jebait.
Der war rechts hinter mir und jetzt ist er links vor mir, what?
No joke, ich glaube, der Soundbackmaterial, das glaube ich auch.
Ich meine, offensichtlicher rumbacken, oder guckt euch mal, ja.
Die geile, die Abtastrate der Maus auf der PS4 ist huge.
Ich meine, das hat gar nicht so einen riesen Vorteil durch Maus und Tastatur.
Du hast bestimmt nur den zweiten, der zweite war tot.
Ich konnte die gar nicht mehr hören.
Da ist Nat mittlerweile geöffnet, die wozu?
Also wenn das ernsthaft dedicated Servers sind, musst du keinen Nat öffnen.
Nat öffnen, dass man überhaupt Nat, das überhaupt, ganz ehrlich Leute,
dass überhaupt sowas wie Nat noch im Menü drinne steht 2019, ist lächerlich.
Da sollte sich keiner Gedanken machen mehr müssen.
Oh, die haben keinen Bock gegen den Poggers zu spielen.
Ich meine, jedes andere Game, außer Call of Duty, braucht keinerlei rumgefuddelt
mit irgendwelchem Nat-Port-Forwarding oder irgendeinem Crap.
Das geht einfach.
Stellt euch doch mal vor, ihr müsstet für jedes verkackte Online-Game,
was ihr spielt, irgendwelche Port-Weiterleitung machen.
Das war vielleicht mal 2005 der Fall, wobei selbst da war das nicht der Fall.
Du musstest, um 2000 CS zu spielen, nie Ports weiterleiten, nie.
Außer du willst den Server aufmachen.
Docs.
Also in Docs mache ich das immer gerne.
Ich bleibe hinter der Wand stehen, werfe eine Flash rüber.
Wir haben gerade keine Flash.
Und wenn er gestunt ist, gehe ich weiter oder mein Team-Mate kann was machen.
Oh, wir haben einen Stim.
Wow, wow, wow.
Mein Dude weiß jetzt, wo der ist, mein Dude weiß, wo der ist.
Alter, verzieht das Ding.
Boah, das Ding verzieht ja wie Sau.
Damit triffst du nichts im Dauerfeuer aus der Hüfte.
Zu früh geschossen.
Easy win.
Nein, das war nicht easy.
Der Typ hat es vercheckt zur Fahne zu gehen.
LMG legit.
Da gucken wir mal, ob wir einen im Spawn erwischen.
Jawoll, sehr schön.
Warum hat das Spiel eigentlich keine Ping-Anzeige?
Die fühlt sich so an mit der Maus an der PS4.
Die fühlt sich auf jeden Fall besser mit dem Controller.
Aber wie die Maus abgetastet wird, müsst ihr euch mal angucken.
Das ist schon besser als Controller.
Ha, da wollte er mich schnupptun.
Wo ist der Apex Legends?
Für mich ist das das beste Battle Royale-Game.
Wo wird gecampt, Leute?
Wenn es drauf ankommt, treffe ich nicht.
Und fliegt der zweite auch noch durch den Arm durch.
Also, auf der wird das Klämer gefickt.
Was, what the f.
Was ist das?
Ich stand an der Scheißfahne.
WTF?
Okay
Ach, der Typ ist gelieft
Wie findest du die Alpha oder Beta, ist egal
Es ist halt ein bisschen wenig, ne, ein bisschen wenig
Also, wen sperrst du mal?
Okay
Gott
Oh, einer noch
Hier gehts, Shotgun Runde
Ich hasse Shotgun Runden
Wir jumpen jetzt direkt da hoch
Es ist so dumm, dass man nichts hört, wenn man gehittert wird
Ich hab mich selbst geflasht
Ich hab mich selbst geflasht, oh meine Fresse
Final Round
What the fuck?
Scheiße
Ach, du Kacke
Vor allem, wie er wieder zwei Treffer ausgehalten hat
Aber der hat das gut, also der hat das genauso muss
Was sollte er anders machen?
Das war schon recht clever gemacht
Jodo, da musst du Jodo, der hatte keine Chance
Ein Hit und er wär tot gewesen
Was ist überhaupt die Messerntaste?
Ja, huge Abtastrate von der Maus wieder
Sieht man hier irgendwie die Tasten
Belegung von dem Ding
V?
Altmäßig auf dem P-
Ich weiß nicht ob das-
Okay, probier's mal aus
Ich hoffe, wir haben ein mittlerer Maustest
Müssen wir mal ausprobieren
Numpad 7
Numpad 7, jetzt wird wahrscheinlich eine total beknackte Position sein
Okay, was haben wir jetzt wieder?
King
Das sieht aus wie Killhouse aus Squad 4
Und irgendwie-
Ich mein, guckt euch mal die Maps an
Es sind kleine Maps
Aber ich mein, auch wenn es kleine Maps sind
Könnte man ein bisschen was ausgefallenes machen
Aber wir haben jetzt- Was haben wir gekriegt?
Docks, einen Schrottplatz, ein Lagerhaus
Und einen Wald mit drei Autos drinne
Warum war das-
Also langsam komm ich mir verarscht vor mit den Treffern
Das-
Also zwei Treffer waren auf jeden Fall 100 pro drauf
Am Anfang
Leute, ich quitte
Ich quitte, äh, ich rage quitte
Der hat mich übrigens verarscht
Rage quitte
Okay, ich bin jetzt hier
Ich bin jetzt hier
Stimm ist eigentlich das an die 50 Waffen
Wo soll ich das wissen? Keine Ahnung
Ekt
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich mit, mit
30 Aufsätzen oder so zusammengerechnet
Dann vielleicht
Okay da macht das, der carried mich
Oh Shotgun Rolle
Oh Knife
Der Typ macht das, der carried mich
Sehr gut 6-2
Der flax
Oder wie auch immer
I flex
Wurde ich gemessert?
War das ein Messer?
Der hat mich gemessert
Zum Glück geht der I-Flax so ab
Also ich trage definitiv nicht dazu bei, dass wir gewinnen gerade
Okay
Hey
9-2
Okay
Nice
Das war eben auch ziemlich glücklich
10-3
Das würde ich mal sagen
So sieht es aus, wenn man hart gecarried wird
Ist die Alpha auf dem PC verfügbar?
Nein
Ist sie nicht
Achso ja das liegt daran, weil ich eine Tastatur angeschlossen habe
Das ist aber auch im fertigen Game wohl möglich
Bloß dass man im fertigen Game mit Maus und Tastatur mit Leuten gematched wird
Die auch Maus und Tastatur spielen
Also unter anderem auch wenn du Crossplay an hast mit dem PC
Ich würde beispielsweise auf jeden Fall Crossplay ausschalten
Wenn ich dabei auf der Tastatur spiele
Weil mit einer normalen Playstation gegen 144Hz 200 FPS
Richtiges Full HD PC bist du halt schreckt
Dux
Ui, gleich war wieder schön geleafed
Ich frage mich ob nachjoinen geht
Also wenn jetzt irgendein Typ auf Matchmaking klickt
Ob der dann hier reingematched wird
Und jointes Matchmaking auch
Okay, wir haben gewonnen
Okay, nachjoinen ist klar, aber ob das Matchmaking reinmatched
Aber anscheinend nicht
Ich finde das Spiel optisch gar nicht schlecht
Die Maps sind optisch total für'n Arsch
Ich mein, ich mein, ernsthaft
Man baut Minimaps für diesen Spielmodus
Man baut Minimaps
Und dann kriegt man es noch nicht mal gebacken oder noch nicht mal geschissen
Für diese Minimaps irgendwie mal halbwegs ansprechendes Settings zu verwenden
Ich mein es wäre jetzt wirklich nicht schwer gewesen
Ich meine, ein Ausschnitt, die werden, ich hoffe im fertigen Game sind die Maps nicht auch
Nur Wald, Schrottplatz, Schrottplatz und Docks
Huge Bits, 100 Stück, Dankeschön
Hazelwood PG
Ich mein, das ist Schrottplatz Nummer 1
Die Map wo wir da vorletztens, eigentlich, das eine ist Schrotthalle, das andere ist Schrottplatz
Und das andere ist nochmal Schrottplatz, das andere ist Wald
So, dann haben wir alle Maps
Gucken wir mal, ob wir die geschniped kriegen
Show them what we do
What the fuck
Monkeys
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, was Mele, was Narcan überhaupt für ein Knopf ist
Mal kurz checken, was ist Narcan?
V
Get knifed
Ok, was ist Narcan überhaupt für ein Knopf?
Zack
V?
Ok, ist es V?
Ich muss jetzt erstmal hier rüber
Ja, V
Ok
Die Pistole fühlt sich nicht gut an
Also, die Desert Eagle fühlt sich richtig nice an
Das knallt richtig
Goethe Straße Map
Fühlt sich echt so an
Goethe Straße, Louis Vuitton Store
Man, fuck
Ja
Darf der sich denn so früh wieder bewegen?
Ja, man kann nicht sprain mit den Pistolen, das muss ich ja auch mal langsam lernen
Man kann einfach nicht sprain
Take fire
What?
On to the next round, pick it up
Ha, der Typ erinnert mich
Ah, kann nicht aus
Bloop
Jawoll, endlich mal try the map Waffe wieder
So, wir gehen erstmal auf unseren Headclitch Spot
Ach, man kann da drauf?
Ok, das ist ja cool
Ist die Lage?
Dann gefickt
Ja
Voll
Das sind so diese typischen Call of Duty Tode
Du schießt drauf
Und er schießt auch drauf
Und irgendwie stirbt man selbst
Ich bin halt alt, Pfeifert
Ach, es wird sowas von umgestellt
What?
Na, also, ich hab schon genug
Ich hab schon genug
Irgendwas Head Emotes
Ok
Der hat's, der hat's
Vorhaus hab ich nicht
Ich hab schon genug
Mega Animation
Max hast du den anderen
Es gibt keinen anderen Modus
Der andere Modus ist genau das gleiche
Wie der Modus
Der Dude chargt sich hier einen ab
Ich wollt übrigens sprinten
Und nicht flashen
Habt ihr gesehen wie er geflitzt ist?
Und wie gefällt dir die Alpha?
Ja, ich hab's heute schon im Video gesagt
Ich glaube nicht, dass das hier der neue E-Sport Shit wird
Ich find's
Ich find's mal ein neuer Ansatz
Aber ich find's eigentlich nicht
Nicht
Alter, ich war schon wieder unten
Das ist eigentlich nicht gut
Ich mein die Maps
Guckt euch die Maps an
Da sieht einer mehr nach Schrottplatz aus
Als die andere
Ok
Final Round
Rep
Text
Nur PS4
Ich halte aber von dieser
Exklusivitätsgeschichte auch nichts
Das Waffenfeeling ist tatsächlich ziemlich gut
Das ist PS4
Zum 570
War in Folge gerade
Willst du die Vollversion spielen?
Weiß ich nicht
Ich warte mal auf die andere Beta
Das hab ich bei den letzten paar Cots auch so gemacht
Obwohl ich mir die meisten gekauft hab
Sogar noch
Das einzige Cot was ich mir nicht gekauft hab
Nee, zwei
Infinite Warfare hab ich mir auf jeden Fall nicht gekauft
Und für Advanced Warfare bin ich mir...
Doch Advanced Warfare hab ich mir gekauft
So wir machen jetzt Trick 17
Wir warten jetzt hier und dann Flashen wir rüber
Oh fuck wir haben gar kein Flash
Es rockelt
Alter es ist huge rockeln
Boah
Ich hab übrigens nichts gehört
Oh
Okay
Der eine der ist wieder gelieft
Ich hoffe wenn sie das
Wenn sie das releasen
Wir campen jetzt hier einfach
Spritze drücken
Ah
Das ist doof
Wenn er gelieft wird
Ich hoffe wenn sie das irgendwie halbwegs
Competitive gestalten werden
Müssen sie auch
irgendwelche Punkte verteilen
Und auch negativ
Punkte wenn einer lieft
Weil das ist halt voll Arsch
What
Ich sehe die Truppen across the map nicht
Ich höre und sehe nichts
Oder so wie CRCS direkt bannen jo
Das ist übrigens nur einer
Fuck
Na toll Max
Oh
Ich höre das nicht gegen einen Verlierer
Anscheinend schon
Boah der out uns alleine
Ich denke die meisten Leute
Ich hab's heute auch im Video gesagt
Die meisten Leute wollen eigentlich Cod gar nicht spielen
Um hier irgendwie so ein Zwei was das Zwei stellt
Oder so zu machen
Die meisten Leute wollen Cod spielen
Was wollen die meisten
Ich glaube also wenn dieser Modus hier
Erfolg haben soll
Da müssen sie die Maps anders machen
Ich finde die Maps ziemlich in Crap
Wie ist der Dude
Ich sehe nichts
Was sollste machen
Du musst zur Fahne
Herr 04
Das läuft ja wieder super
Weil wenn ich mich aufrege
Dann bin ich so dämlich
Ja bin ich
Aber ich sehe echt keine Gegner
Ich würde so gern mal mit einer PS4 Pro
Ausprobieren ob das besser ist
Ist es nicht
Ich sehe halt echt nichts
Ich sehe nichts in dem Spiel
Aber die Runde ist besonders erniedrigend gerade
Ich kann das bei Amazon kaufen
Und zurückschicken
Bei 05 gegen einen
Wobei der sich halt auch zurück lehnen kann
Wir müssen den pushen
Warum klauchst du den Keks von Max
Anzeige ist raus
Direkt anzeigen
Einfach Polizei
Der Edge Quit
Ich glaube es geht los
Zu doof
Du meinst er hat ein paar zweimal das 1 mehr Leben
Nee glaube ich nicht
Oder
Nee
Und selbst wenn
Theoretisch hast du mit zwei Leuten immer noch einen Vorteil
Du hast mit zwei Leuten immer noch den Vorteil
Okay ja kann sein dass du
Ich meine es wäre ja nur fair das wenn das nur
Wenn das nur ein paar Leute mehr haben
Dann wäre es nur fair
Okay
Ich meine es wäre ja nur fair das wenn das nur
Wenn das einer ist dass er da wenigstens mehr Leben hat
Ach wir haben weniger
Okay sind wir deswegen so schnell down
Naja
Also was mir an dem Modus
Also was zumindest verbesserungswürdig ist an dem Modus
Was sich aber nicht ändern wird
Ist
Die Maps
Die Maps wirken irgendwie einfach lieblos
Lieblos zusammen geschust hat
Und auch nicht als hätten sie jetzt
Irgendwie so eine gewisse Finesse
Es ist eigentlich eher
Glück abhängig wäre wo lang geht
Als dass es jetzt irgendwie großartig taktisch wäre
Und ich habe das Problem ich sehe die Gegner nicht ohne Scheiß
Ich weiß nicht ob ich zu
Zu verwöhnt bin von 1080p
Mit ordentlichen FPS
Aber ich sehe die Gegner nicht in dem Spiel
Oh wir spielen gegen
Hier ein tolles Squad
Und das sind Call of Duty Tote wo ich nicht verstehe warum man stirbt
Nein
Die haben zeitgleich aufeinander geschossen
Wieso sieht 30 FPS auf der Konsole besser aus als auf dem PC
Kann ich mal unbedingt sagen dass es besser aussieht
Okay Pre-Fire auf dem Kopf
Also gerade ist es mir echt zu doof
Zu verwöhnt
Gut auf dem PC ist das so auf der Konsole nicht
Okay
Ich habe gerade hinter mir einen gehört übrigens
What? Alter wo sind die Gegner?
Das Menschliche auch kein 27 stimmt nicht
24 deswegen stream ich doch auch auf 48 FPS
Das ist das doppelte davon für beide
Du wirst so gefickt von zwei Leuten die zusammen spielen
Das ist krass
Aber jetzt habe ich nicht gerechnet dass der oben steht nach der Flash
Tja da machst du nichts
Ich muss morgen echt mit jemanden zusammen spielen
Ich glaube dann kann er es tatsächlich richtig Bock machen
Wir können den Gamescom Auftritt von Axel Force anschauen
Davon gibt es ein Video
Wie lang geht das?
Wie lang geht das, brac Lord?
Wie lang geht das, Habarro?
Eine Stunde!
Nein, eine Stunde, dass geht das nicht
Wir können jetzt eben jetzt mit Axel Force zu G closet Presse
Wie lange geht das hier, Bauer?
Eine Stunde, nein, eine Stunde lang können wir jetzt hier nicht Axel Force angucken.
Also eine Stunde Axel Force ertrage ich nicht.
Das wird zu hardcore, äh, ne.
Eine Stunde Axel Force geht nicht.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Was erzählt er denn so?
Drohen sich das wenigstens?
Wie findest du, dass die Map nur gespiegelt ist?
Was meinst du? Du meinst hier Docs?
Die Jäger sterben nicht heute.
Ach, ich bin alleine.
Ah, verstehe.
Er wirkt nicht ganz unsympathisch, ok?
Was?
Das war eigentlich gar nicht so blödsich da hinzulegen.
Guck mal.
Kann ich hier dran mounten? Ne.
Der war oben rechts.
Ich hab Schritte oben rechts gehört.
Also der Sound, der macht mich fertig.
Du musst aggressiver spielen.
Das ist schwierig.
Zwei.
Ist genug trubt.
Die Waffe ist bereit.
Guck mal, wie verschwommen das da oben ist.
Da siehst du nix.
Ich war drauf, ich war drauf.
Ich spiel 40% der Zeit fast alleine.
Na, so schlimm ist es nicht.
So schlimm ist es nicht.
Ok.
Hab ich den ernsthaft nicht getroffen?
Hab ich den ernsthaft nicht einmal getroffen gerade?
Er ist um die Ecke und hat mich one shotted?
Toll.
Ich glaube die Optik ist auf der PS4 Pro besser.
Weil die Auflösung ist halt rotz.
Ne, ne, ich hab hochgestellt auf 1080p.
Aber in-game läuft das Ding wahrscheinlich auch nicht viel höher.
Aber die Auflösung ist rotz.
Ich seh null.
Ich seh nichts an Gegnern.
Und ich würd's halt gern mal auf einer PS4 Pro spielen.
PS4 Pro ist auch kacke.
Irgendein Vorteil muss die PS4 Pro haben.
Also ich hab mir ein Vergleichsvideo angeguckt.
Von Black Ops 4 zu normaler PlayStation 4 Version Black Ops 4.
Der einzige Unterschied war halt, dass Black Ops 4 auf der Pro ne ganze Ecke schärfer ist.
Du siehst da hinten doch nix.
Und es ruckelt.
Also ich weiß nicht wo das Problem gerade ist.
Das war nicht ein Hit!
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Noch ein Hit war's.
Also es sieht besser aus als die letzten Cots.
Das muss man sagen.
Ihr kommt sofort, schieß ich mit Watte!
Und ich bin einfach schon alt und meine Kugeln fliegen vorbei.
Zu alt.
Wascht ab!
What?
Die sind gerade und nicht irgendwie da.
Life is over.
Willst du auf den PC?
Nein.
PS4.
PC würde ich gerne spielen.
Schreckte.
War der in der Mitte?
Der war da?
Okay.
Knapp.
So sieht's da aus.
Ich kann jetzt nicht vorwärts.
Wenn ich jetzt vorwärts gehe, kriege ich aufs Maul.
Aber wir gewinnen, wenn wir Zeit abwarten.
Gewinnen wir.
Eigentlich ist die Regel für den Modus übelster Bullshit, wenn man sich mal durch den Kopf gehen lässt.
Der der den ersten Hit trifft, kann einfach sich hinlegen und campen.
Ihr macht den ersten Hit.
Ach nee, nicht schon wieder gegen einen.
Übrigens, ich hab in die Richtung geschossen, weil ich den roten...
Guck mal, da siehst du doch nichts.
Seht ihr den?
Also ich hab den gesehen wegen dem roten Ding über den Kopf und halt ein bisschen was sich vom Hintergrund abgehoben hat.
Aber du siehst den Gegner null.
Ah fuck, wir haben ne Spritze.
Kann man hier rein?
Und der kann sich jetzt einfach rein abcampen.
Du weißt halt null, wo er ist.
Dadurch, dass die Maps halt so mini sind, so wirkliche Timings hat das auch nicht.
Der Typ campt hintenrum irgendwo wieder.
Also ich war es nicht.
Der Blockwatcher sagt, ich brauch nur ein Pixel vom Gegner, um ihn zu sehen.
Er ist 5-Head.
Huge 5-Head.
5-Header ist das schon.
Ich muss mal Streamlabs aufmachen, ob ich irgendwelche Subs und Gedöns übersehen hab.
Wen haben wir denn hier?
Resubs, Roffel, ne, den hatten wir schon.
XFatal1337 und da Martin.
Doch, die hatten wir schon.
Nice.
Hab ich euch übrigens schon erzählt, Leute, wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime Account habt, könnt ihr den ganzen kostenlos mit eurem Twitch Prime Account verknüpfen.
Und wisst ihr, was ihr damit machen könnt.
Ihr könnt einen Streamer eurer Wahl mit einem Tier-1-Sub unterstützen, ohne dass es euch was kostet.
Ist das nicht was?
Das ist huge.
Nice.
Oh, geht los.
Dann wurde es deaktiviert.
Wow.
Wir machen jetzt huge, huge Play.
Ha.
Hab ich doch gesehen.
Kann jeder gerade zocken.
Jeder, der eine PS4 hat.
Und in Deutschland leider nur jeder, der Playstation Plus hat.
Weil du Altersverifikation brauchst.
Okay.
Ende hoch, Wochenende.
Du kannst dir allerdings, wenn du keinen Playstation Plus hast und trotzdem eine PS4 hast, kannst du dir einfach einen Fake Account UK machen.
Okay, die gehen rechts.
Die müssen rechts gehen.
Alter.
Das Holz.
Wie ist dein Eindruck von 1 bis 10 jetzt?
Ich kann nichts zu dem Game sagen, ehrlich.
Der Modus ist nicht sagend.
Die Maps sind mini.
Und auf der PS4 spiele ich nicht gerne.
Alter, Leute, rushed halt mal vor, ey.
Der ist oben, Kollege, der ist oben.
Jawoll, nice.
Hallo, Ex.
Ex.
Veno.
Sagt man, geht nicht Classic Vow los gerade?
Oder nächstes Wochenende?
Jetzt machen wir mal.
Was? Was?
Wollt ihr mir wirklich sagen, das war kein Hit?
Oder trifft einmal?
Alter.
Das ist auch so verwaschen.
Die Hit-Rack ist ultra für den Arsch.
Wie oft ich heute schon vorbeigeschossen hab.
Ich mein eben nicht, eben hab ich verschissen.
Also eben an der Flagge.
Aber die Hit-Rack ist so krass für den Arsch.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Fuck.
Was ist hier?
Ach, da ist wieder geliefter, Dude.
Und alt, alt bin ich auch.
Ja, das ist doof, gegen eins zu spielen wieder.
Wobei, komm.
Yolo Rush.
Der Afk, der Typ?
Ich glaub, der ist Afk.
Die World-Side ist echt?
Ja, das hab ich gestern.
Ist dem Chat gestern schon aufgefallen.
Dem Cute-Chat.
Pass mal auf Leute jetzt.
Passt auf.
Okay, oder auch nicht.
Aber eine Runde machen wir noch.
Kann man eine Uptime machen?
Please?
Ach stimmt Leute.
Ja, für Fels geradein.
Ich hab wieder mal vergessen.
Ich hab mal wieder vergessen, den Kram zu resetten.
Ja, das resetet sich jedes Mal.
Shit.
Okay, wir machen den Color Mode.
Vielleicht soll ich mal heller machen.
Vielleicht seh ich die Gegner dann besser.
E.
MonkaS Smoke.
Moin.
C-Drix.
Insane.
Kann man noch höher machen.
Face.
Echtes Face-Setting hier.
Der Elsa aus 68, Warrior.
Vor den Streams wusste ich nicht mal, dass du
full on Weep bist, bin ich überhaupt nicht.
Der Sebaro hat mich so weit gebracht.
Ich guck aber so gut wie nix.
Aber haben wir eine Granate? Flash?
Molotov, okay.
Oh Gott, ist das hell.
Ich seh nichts.
Ich seh noch weniger was.
Das ist viel zu hell.
Der Sebaro ist Mord.
Alter, please, nicht leaven.
Also, irgendjemand hat gesagt, gefühlt 40% alleine.
Ja.
Allerdings, wenn man mit einem rechnet,
Gegner auch alleine.
Dann.
Das war wirklich 40%.
Okay, easy.
Win.
Ist das fucking hell, ja.
Ich hab gerade die Helligkeit auf 75% gestellt.
Kann man Luft anhalten, nein, schnell.
Jetzt gucken, wie ich's mit...
Man kann schon ganz gut einzelne Pixel bewegen.
Nee, das geht nicht ohne Gegner weiter.
Das hört dann irgendwann auf.
Allerdings ein bisschen zu langsam,
weil das joint ja keiner mehr rein.
Die könnten direkt 3-2-1 ausmachen.
Mit Luft anhalten weiß ich.
I know.
Come on, game, machen wir noch.
Ach ja, hat jemand zufällig Abtime schon gemacht?
Abtime?
Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Ach ja, Abtime.
Zwei Stunden.
Oh Gott, ist das anstrengend, ey.
Easy.
Nein, nicht PC, PS4.
Das ist anstrengendes Game.
Oh Gott, nein, nein, nein.
Ich dodge jetzt, ich dodge jetzt.
Pine, Pine, Pine, Pine spielen wir nicht.
Pine sucked.
Ich spiel morgen mal mit...
Ich muss mal gucken.
Entweder mit dem Underswirl oder mit dem Shox.
Shox wollte ich auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Runden spielen.
Ja.
Wieder docks, okay.
Guck, die liefen schon, weil sie eine Maus sehen.
View player profile.
Gibt's denn da?
Oh, das geht nur, das geht nur mit dem Controller jetzt, oder wie?
Okay.
Ja, den gibt's noch.
Der hat gestern geströmt.
So, jetzt diese Runde versuch ich mal ein bisschen aggressiver zu spielen.
Ich spiel wirklich immer oft zu weit hinten.
Okay, die ist der Weg sucked hier.
Die gehen jetzt trotzdem...
Ich guck mal, wo mein Mate hingeht.
Boah, ist das hell, ich seh nix.
Ah, Gott, wieder von der Seite weggefickt, ey.
All das einplanen, ja.
Oh, wack, ich hatte letztens ein übelst...
Wir hatten letztens eine übelst geile Idee für eine WoW oder für eine Online-Guilde mit alten Säcken.
Ah, fuck, wie war der Name?
Gestern Pro, heute Klo.
Was sagst du?
Ich find das eine richtig gute Idee.
Gestern Pro, heute Klo.
Würde es irgendwas auf Altersheim geben, was sich reimt, ja?
Also irgendwas, weil gestern Pro klingt halt gut, klingt halt wie...
Achtung, Yolo, Yolo, Yolo Rush.
Die sind hinter uns.
Okay, gut.
Eats.
Easy.
Ich hab irgendwas runtergeschmissen gerade.
Die kommen oben her.
Fuck.
Verschissen.
Die kann man ja einfach spielen, du brauchst einen PS4.
Und in Deutschland brauchst du Plus.
Plus brauchst du nur zum Downloaden, nicht zum Spielen.
Was irgendwie...
Es hört sich bescheuert an, aber es ist so.
War ich nicht drauf?
Aber ich hab gar nicht geschossen bei dem.
Okay, was?
Merkwürdiges Zeug passiert hier.
Huge Chat, aber huge cute.
Jetzt schneibt er, jetzt sollte man seine Waffe wechseln.
Bam.
Warum nur in DE?
Tja, weil Altersfreigabe und so.
Jetzt wird er gescopt, jetzt wird er gescopt, Leute.
Es ist ein bisschen hell, oder?
Das Bild.
Kennt ihr den nicht auch?
So minimal, so hell.
Die Maus fühlt sich besser an als das Gamepad, aber immer noch so.
Das Gamepad aber immer noch super schwammig.
Manchmal kann man sich Mountain Hill gucken, mal so Rainbow Siege-mäßig um die Ecke gucken.
Okay, was auch immer.
Aber die Mausabtastrate ist sehr komisch irgendwie.
Ja, merkwürdig.
Altersheim shootet rein, richtig.
Sag mal, ist da eine Noob-Tube unten dran, seh ich das richtig?
Ah!
Da hat er Noob-Tube reingenooobtubt.
Der Modus ist richtig anstrengend, wisst ihr das?
Einer geht noch.
Der Modus ist richtig anstrengend.
Aber guck mal hier, also in-game fühlt es sich nicht ganz so schlimmer als im Hauptmenü,
aber wir spielen gegen Easy.
Guck mal, wie easy easy es ist.
Oh fuck, Magazin war leer.
Aber der ist mega angehittet, der Dude.
Das könnten sie sich übrigens auch sparen.
Aber das geht eigentlich nur auf den Zack, dass sie dir die Kill-Kammer angucken muss.
Hallo, kannst du mal da hochspringen, Kollege?
Ich wollte nicht hochspringen.
Ist klar.
Ich hör nix.
Und hör auf zu stöhnen.
Mitten rechts in der Ecke ist er.
Wie soll, was ist denn das für eine hirnristige, für eine absolut hirnristige Posey für den
Punkt, ey.
Er kann einfach hinten an der Mauer sitzen, am spawnen und in den Punkt gucken.
Alter, was ist das?
Hirnrissig, richtig hirnrissig, ja.
Und dass man nix hört, ja, dass man nix hört, ist auch mega beknackt, ey.
Das regt mich richtig auf.
Was?
Hä?
Ich mein, guckt euch mal die Map an.
Ganzhaft.
Geradeaus von spawn zu spawn.
Was ist das denn?
Was ist das?
Wer hat sich das ausgedacht?
Wer dachte, ey, das, so muss man eine Map bauen, so ist das eine gute...
Was charget der denn da rüber?
Jawoll, voll in Sack.
Sidestep 90.
Ja, machs gut.
Ok, achte, achte, jetzt wird er weggestellt.
Sniper got 360.
Oh, oh mein Gott.
Alter, ich hab wieder zeitgleich geschossen mit dem.
Ich hab's mir überlegt, vielleicht geh ich doch zu Optik.
Oder was gibt's denn sonst noch?
Optik, Fatality, dann gehen wir zum Franzosen am besten.
Kein Hit, Leute, das war so ein Hit.
Schreckt.
Wenn die Hitrack mal hittet, dann wird das auch was.
Moin.
Unit Skinny.
Diese Spawn-Geschieße, ey, meine Fresse.
Das Game regt mich jetzt schon auf.
Ich hoffe für das Spiel, ernsthaft, ich hoffe echt für das Game,
dass wir ordentlich TDM und Domination haben.
Weil das kann ich auf Dauer nicht spielen, da krieg ich absolute Anfälle.
Cloud 9, klar, gibt's die noch.
Envy.
Aber so die richtig krassen Scopers sind eigentlich, glaube ich, wirklich Face und Optik.
Wie ist der ApoRed Clan nochmal?
Komm, wir gehen den ApoRed Clan.
Digga, willst du meinen Clan joinen?
Digga, kritischer Hase, Digga.
Die Pistole macht überhaupt keinen Damage, das ist so pschu pschu pschu pschu pschu pschu pschu pschu pschu.
Und immer noch nicht tot.
Apokalypto.
bei
Ne ne ne die heißen die heißen nicht die er da hieß die hießen apokalypto die heißen doch jetzt anders
Heißes impact oder im was ich impact
Nature ja das ist irgendwie fort fort 20 thieves
Impeckter
Macht's laune ja, ja und nähe ja und nähe
Das neue team von masse erwiesen die noch mal ich habe es da ist jetzt ja ist er hat
Dings hier shocks und und ich weiß gar nicht wie das aktuelle team da alles dabei ist
Impact ist wieder was anderes oder
Jetzt etwas mit v glaube ich am anfang jetzt
Ist auch egal hast du doch kontakt mit der fabian klar
Ja
Moment
Was hält der dude aus
Was hält der aus ich habe den acht mal getroffen oder so
Was ist das denn
Was hält der aus das ist einfach mal nicht geplendet und das game regt mich auf
Achtung wir wir stehen jetzt hier und flaschen rüber der braucht hilfe der tut
Auch nicht wall bang wall bang molly
Die pistole meine fresse
Und die schüssel connecten weder später irgendwie gar nicht so
Keine moin haxel ad endlich meine ordentliche waffe schrecken gucken wir den wall bang kann big brain
Oh
Das war vereint das war vereint
Was ist das eigentlich habe ich dieses komische im auto im chat überhaupt freigeschaltet oder ist das was anderes
96 hätte
Schreck so an uns wieder richtig
Die mod ach so das war ich nicht
Oh lmg legit time
Aha erwischt zockt der kabum auch mw ich weiß es nicht
Warum heißt du wupplos warst du nicht mal max fps ich war auf twitch war ich noch nie max fps
Es hat hauptsächlich den grund weil ich
Den das nie geplant habe weil ich nie geplant habe damit zu streamen mit dem account
Erstmal weggespray und prägt wohl ist eigentlich ist eigentlich wupps mittlerweile freigeschaltet
Ich wollte eigentlich wieder gleich runter hüpfen ein wupps ist nicht freigeschaltet
Scheiße auch ein kollege du reißt das jetzt wow huge
Montage
Volta 360 gerade achtung jetzt wird jetzt jetzt war was plat
Ich stehe voll in der F-
Meine Fresse, warum verliere ich diese Kackduelle immer?
Gibt's doch nicht.
Das liegt daran, ich kann euch genau sagen woran das liegt.
Weil ich der übelste Movement-Krüppel bin.
In dem Game.
Weil ich richtig die ganze Zeit in der Kackduelle verliere.
Und das ist das, was ich hier für einen Kackduell finde.
Weil ich richtig dämlich bin.
Jemand der mit Speed reinjumpt und weiß wo ich stehe.
Und der wusste ja ungefähr wo ich stehe.
Hat jeden Vorteil den Skip dabei.
Ich muss nicht einfach so sinnlos rumstehen.
Wie gewinnt das jetzt noch?
Shit.
Fuck.
Jawoll, nice.
Jetzt kommt's, Ravan.
Zockst du auf Battlefield 3?
Das hat noch einen aktiven Rush-Server, Battlefield 3.
Wir können gleich mal gucken.
Ihh, das ist diese Drecks-Sucker-Shotgun.
Shit.
Scheiße.
Fuck.
Vorbei geaimt.
Wollte ich nicht schon vor Gefühl eine halbe Stunde oder so Schluss machen?
Gibt's eigentlich neue Infos zu Bad Company 3?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Das ist die einzige Map, die ich halbwegs...
Wobei selbst dies sagt.
Guck dir mal, rechts spawnen, links spawnen.
Wer baut sowas?
Okay, jetzt werden sie erstmal geschneibert.
Erstmal weggeschneibert werden sie jetzt.
Erstmal schön weggescoped.
Ahh, man.
Ich bin nicht da rausgegangen.
Der muss einfach nur auf das stehen abdrücken.
Die nächste Schneiber Runde.
Wer zuerst da ist und rauskommt, hat gewonnen.
Ist nicht so wie ein CS, wo du dann teilweise noch einen Vorteil hast, wenn du derjenige bist, der eben in der Bewegung ist.
Was ist denn nix?
Wir machen das jetzt anders.
Ich hab zu lang gespielt jetzt.
Geht nix mehr.
Zeig mir doch nicht immer diesen scheiß Kill da nochmal.
Mach einfach weiter.
Okay, das finde ich jetzt eine gute Idee.
Kannst du das mal im Discord in den Channel, in das Channel-Emote, in den Emote-Vorschlag-Channel schreiben?
Ich krieg so krass auf die Fresse immer.
Warum?
Alter, pass auf.
Ja, sehr gut.
Dankeschön, Silberau.
Sehr gut.
Das Film mit dem roten Keks finde ich übelst nice.
Das ist dann WubRage.
Hier sieht man wieder nix.
Ich hab nichts gehört, null von links, kein Sound und nichts.
Reicht das nicht, weil man im Container drin steht?
Ist NoobTube gleich YouTube, wat?
YouTube war schon immer NoobTube.
Wenn du dir anguckst, dass keiner der Let's-Player auch nur ansatzweise irgendwas spielen kann.
Wie oft muss ich den Typ treffen?
Der hat drei Bursts gefressen.
Oder zwei.
Zwei Bursts hat der Typ gefressen.
Was ist mit dem los?
Ach, der Letze hat mich mal getroffen.
Wer erinnert sich an den NoobTube Song?
Der NoobTube Song.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
New Mode.
Zeig mal her.
On-Site Procurement.
Was?
Auf Deutsch bitte.
You can explore the map und find...
Ja, der Modus ist...
Also der Modus hier, ich zeig euch das mal, der ist noch dümmer als der andere.
Den Payflow Song, der kommt mir auch noch bekannt vor.
Der Modus ist ganz merkwürdig.
Hier kommt man, den spielt gar keiner.
Ach doch.
Eigestuhl 69.
Was ein Name.
Ja, ich auch.
Ich hab doch schon gesagt, ich bräuchte mal einen.
Entweder den Undersuril oder den Shox.
Aber heute nicht mehr.
Wir spielen morgen.
Das reicht jetzt.
Welche Modi kann man aktuell spielen?
Ja, nur den hier.
Nur den hier.
Okay, den spielt keiner, Leute.
Den spielt keiner.
Also ein Win noch.
Ein Win noch.
Dann...
Dann haben wir mal Schluss.
Und schon genug von Kurt, ja.
Eigentlich schon.
Dann Axel Foss.
Ist das wirklich interessant?
Ich kann es mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass man das so spannend ist, Axel Foss anzugucken.
Legiona1498.
Dankeschön Twitch Prime.
Big Brain, Huge IQ, Subscriber.
Wie treffen die so gut?
Warum treffe ich die nicht?
Die Frage.
Wie viel wichtigere Frage ist das?
Ja, das könnte sogar sein, dass der Friseur gerade am streamen ist.
Okay, nice.
Nee, ist er nicht?
Okay.
Der müsste doch mal wieder ein bisschen BDO Cryant machen.
Diese komische Waffe.
Was war nochmal Mele?
E, ne?
Nee, fuck.
E?
Vergess das immer.
E war es.
Den hätte ich nahe kämpfen müssen.
Alter, kannst du mal aufhören zu verrecken.
So spät.
Habe ich bei Dark Edge of Camelot kennengelernt?
Richtig, ja.
Haben wir auch.
Rekt.
Das geht viel zu schnell.
Ja, Partypad sehe ich auch so.
Geht viel zu schnell.
Rechts, rechts.
Und auch links, beides.
Ich brauch mal einen, der mich carried.
Ich kann nach zweieinhalb Stunden nicht mehr carryen, geht nicht.
Okay, das muss man jetzt gewinnen, Leute.
Ich will Schluss machen.
Also ich werde garantiert keinen Con spielen, wenn das der einzige Modus ist.
Alter, was geht mit meiner Schneiber ab?
Ich habe zu lange Luft angehalten.
Ich war wieder drauf.
Das Game fuckt mich so krass ab.
Was ist das?
Shotgun Action 4x4.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Wenn die Hits registren, dann geht das auch.
Matchpoint.
Also Leute, ihr müsst jetzt hoffen, dass wir verlieren.
Ich muss hoffen, dass wir gewinnen.
Weil ihr wollt ja wahrscheinlich weiter streben gucken.
Okay, wir haben verloren.
Ich drücke voll die falschen Tasten.
Ich will Nades werfen.
Ich messere, ich messere, wenn ich tactical Nades werfen will.
Okay, gute Waffe.
Rekt.
XHD an All penetriert, Leute.
Die Alpha ist auch nur auf der PS4 spielbar.
Ich schalte...
Nee, das Stream ist noch nicht ganz over.
Ich schalte jetzt erst mal auf den PC um.
Ich schalte auf den PC um.
Mal gucken wir mal.
Weil wir haben ja noch...
Also eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch Zeit.
Aber...
Mehr Kot heute kriege ich nicht gebacken.
Ich muss übrigens mal umstöpseln.
Ich wundere mich die ganze Zeit.
Warum geht meine Tastatur nicht?
Warum geht meine Maus nicht?
Ganz einfach.
Weil ich ja der PLA Station Stöpseln habe.
Ach Leute, ich zeige euch jetzt mal den übelsten Hack für Corsair Tastaturen, dass man mit
ihnen an der PlayStation 4 spielen kann.
Und zwar, pass mal auf.
Laut.
Wenn ihr eine Corsair Tastatur habt, funktioniert die standardmäßig nicht an der PS4.
Also mit dem Namen findet euch keiner, den ich kenne von YouTube auf Twitch.
Das ist auch ein Grund gewesen, warum ich mich nicht umbenannt habe.
Ich glaube der Typ zeigt das hier.
Sag mal, was ist das für eine Auflösung?
Ist er ernsthaft?
Kollege, es ist das Jahr 2018 gewesen und er lädt hoch in 240p.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Ich muss...
Wobei, ich zeige euch das.
Corsair K95, das geht aber auch für die anderen.
Also wenn ihr das Ding verwenden wollt an der PS4, dann müsst ihr F1 und diese Taste
hier.
Also F1 und die Windows.
Was ist denn das?
Die Taste ist das, glaube ich.
Die macht nichts, wenn ich drauf drücke.
Die müsst ihr zusammen gedrückt halten, so für 5, 6, 7, 8 Sekunden.
Und dann fängt hier oben die Roll-Taste zu blinken an.
Sollte hier Probleme haben, ja.
Das versetzt nämlich die Tastatur in irgendwie so einen speziellen Modus und ohne wird sie
zwar erkannt von der PS4, allerdings, ähm, sie funktioniert nicht.
Und sobald das angeschaltet, ist es wunderbar.
Jetzt muss ich das mal wieder rückgängig machen, fällt mir gerade ein.
Erst mal wieder rückgängig machen.
So.
Jetzt habe ich wieder rückgängig gemacht und jetzt erkennt auch mein PC die Tastatur
wieder, weil vorher hatte die nicht, hatte die gar nicht erkannt.
Ja Leute, also wir können jetzt noch, zum Beispiel noch Zeit, wir können noch ein bisschen
schwätzen.
Ähm, was macht eigentlich so mein Video gerade?
XFPD.
Das neue Partei.
Kann das Infinity Board noch?
Und 10k Aufrufe, nice.
Wow, machen wir mal eine Emoji da unten.
Monkey Smoke.
Ich will, nein, ich kann mir Axel Foss nicht geben jetzt.
Kein Axel Foss.
Axel Foss Games, was hat er denn überhaupt erzählt, der Gute?
Axel Foss.
Axel Foss Spiel Minecraft, okay.
Foss?
Würden Sie sich mal kurz vorstellen, wer Sie genau?
Sehr interessant.
Herr Foss, ich habe an Sie zwei Fragen.
Was ist jetzt?
Freit's hin?
Ähm, die Aufbauten, die...
Oh, ich kann mir den Typen nicht geben.
Das geht gerade, das geht nicht.
Jetzt kriege ich Anfälle, das geht nicht.
Axel Foss.
Nee, Leute, kein Axel Foss.
Der Pay, den Payflow Song, genauer, den Payflow Song kann man uns jetzt nochmal anhören.
Der da.
Äh.
Warum ist das Wo?
Nee, passt schon.
Der Payflow Song, ja.
Was?
Das ist nicht der Payflow Song?
Das ist der Payflow Song.
Das ist der Payflow Song, genau.
Audio Delay ist noch drin.
MP3.
Hat gesackt wie Sau, finde ich.
Natürlich kenne ich den Anfang nicht mehr.
Schreckt.
Mache mal Ausrufezeichen Beruf, hier in den Texten, da weiß ich zwölf was ich gerade aktuell
mache, aber ich kann gleich was zu erzählen.
Das war nice, ja.
Ich meine, es ist nicht wirklich meine Musik, aber da geht es überhaupt nicht drum.
Das geht auch um das Feeling vom Game damals, wobei ich MB3, ich habe mich sowas von aufgesägt.
Asch, MB3, das war ja das mit der Reaper-Drohung.
Wo sie alle mit Reaper ihren Campstrike gemacht haben.
Nein, das hat sie nicht gemacht.
Das war gar kein Campstrike, Campstrike war Ghost oder Moab.
Moab.
Moment, Leute.
Ich muss das kurz unterbrechen zum Thema Moab.
So geil.
Das passt nicht zusammen, das ist zu nervig.
Ist der Genetix noch da? Der wollte irgendwas wissen, beruflicher, beruflicher, laufbar, gar nicht was zu erzählen, falls er noch da ist.
Also, ich habe meine Ausbildung gemacht als Fachinformatiker Systemintegration bei einem,
ich kann den Namen nicht, ich will das den Namen nicht sagen, bei einem RZ-Betreiber, Schrägstrich, Hosting-Anbieter, so in die Richtung ging das Ganze.
Da habe ich ja hauptsächlich die ganze Linux-Kramus gelernt damals, weil das, sagen wir so, Anfang des Jahrtausends in diese Richtung war, Linux jetzt noch nicht so, es ist extrem verbreitete, aber da war das schwer angesagt.
Aber da bin ich nicht lange geblieben, ich bin dann nach der Ausbildung gewechselt nach Frankfurt in so einer, ich sag mal eine Bank, es ist nicht wirklich eine Bank, aber es ist im Bankensektor angesiedelt und am Anfang auch ganz normal als Linux-Admin,
wobei ich halt mittlerweile nichts mehr mit Systemadministration am Hut habe. Ich vermisse das manchmal ehrlich gesagt, so ein bisschen Kommandozeilen, Shell-Hacksoren.
Ja, man muss halt auch sehen, so reine Systemadministration stirbt halt ein bisschen aus.
Es ist nicht so, dass man gar keine mehr braucht, auf absehbare Zeit wird man auch welche brauchen, aber durch die ganze Blablabla, SS-Service, Cloud, Funktion, was es alles für Geschichten gibt, wo Leute quasi ihr Kram eben nicht mehr selbst laufen haben, sondern irgendwo anders auslagen,
selbst bei uns ist es jetzt ein ganz großes Thema, die ganzen Sachen nach Azure auszulagern und so.
Also die klassische Systemadministrationsstelle ist im Begriff, eine Bedeutung zu verlieren, ja.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, wenn man auch noch ein paar andere Sachen hinkriegt.
Bei mir war es halt schon immer so, ich hab gerne programmiert. Ich mein, ich hab hier heute relativ viele Leute gesehen, die hier noch nie im Stream gewesen sind.
Aber wir machen ja öfters hier auf Twitch, haben ja öfters Programmier-Streams, zum Beispiel eine Sache, die wir hier zusammen im Stream programmiert haben, ist ein Versand-Tracker.
Der geht jetzt aber nicht, fällt mir gerade ein, weil ich mein, fuck, ich kann ihn euch gar nicht zeigen, weil ich eine Datei einlese, die es hier auf dem Account nicht gibt.
Aber ich kann euch Screenshots von zeigen.
Ja, und nachdem ich schon immer gerne programmiert hab, hab das doch auf Twitter geschrieben,
nachdem ich schon immer gerne programmiert hab, war es für mich halt irgendwie nachliegend, dass ich so ein Zwischending,
also schon lange, bevor es den Namen Devops an sich gab, auch ist er nicht niedlich, deine Chico, bevor es dir diese Bezeichnung als Devops gegeben hat,
hab ich schon die ganze Zeit so ein Zwischending gemacht zwischen EM-Administration und Software-Entwicklung.
Und jetzt gibt es ja den Namen Devops für sowas.
Übrigens, das ist der einzig wahre Hexor-Weg, seine Schuhe zu trocknen, hinterm Server-Rack.
Nur so geht das.
Hab ich denn mal, hab ich denn gepostet?
MKS-T-Shirt, auch ganz wichtig.
Sollte ich jemals Webcam anmachen, dann zieh ich das MKS-T-Shirt an.
Moment, hab ich denn, wo ist denn mein Versandtrack, wo ist denn meine Versandtracker-App?
Ach hier, da ist er doch, so sieht das Ganze aus.
Kannste automatisch deine Trackingnummer verfolgen lassen, ohne dass du sie eingeben musst.
Kannste auch von Hand eingeben, allerdings ist das Programm so clever und kann das automatisch aus den E-Mails auslesen und trackt das Ganze dann für dich.
Es gibt ja zigtausend Versandtracker-Apps, aber die ist next level.
Man hat sogar eine Karte, wo das DHL Auto lang fährt.
So Sachen hab ich schon immer gerne gemacht, deswegen war es irgendwie logisch, dass ich irgendwann mal in diese DevOps-Richtung lande.
Aber es macht auch Spaß.
Das ist wirklich so eine Stelle, wo du Sachen programmieren musst, wo du Sachen vor allem lesen musst, was andere programmiert haben.
Und wo du aber immer noch ab und zu mal ein bisschen am System rumbasteln kannst, das ist eigentlich gut.
Manche würde ich gerne mal wieder ein, zwei Tage mal ein bisschen wirklich direkt auf den Servern selbst Zeugs machen.
Ich würde auch gerne mal wieder öfters ins RZ, ich glaube ich war das letzte Jahr einmal im RZ oder so.
Aber man kann nicht alles haben, ne?
Ja, gibt es sonst noch irgendetwas, was jemand wissen will?
Ich hab heute viele neue Leute im Chat gesehen, ich guck mal, wer alles gefollowed hat.
Oh, den Neon-Nadro hab ich übersehen, Twitch Prime-Sub, dankeschön, bist du noch da, als du noch da bist?
Ja, hab ich übersehen.
Follower seh ich jetzt leider nicht wirklich durch, wer hat hier alle gefollowed?
Genetix, der Staffi, der Bazingo, der Muffin, der Nelson, TakeYoshi, Hofe Didi, PsyloxPlays, Fresh, SpartaTime, Liutasil6, mehr seh ich nicht, was waren heute richtig viele?
Also danke für die ganzen Follows und vor allem danke für die ganzen Subs.
Alle Subs haben bei mir prinzipiell absolut high IQ, muss sein.
Interessierst du dich für Machine Learning?
Ich verfolge das Ganze, es ist nicht, dass ich aktiv irgendwelche Sachen da programmieren würde.
Ja, das stimmt, Oracle SQL ist was, wo man Privates nicht allzu viel mit rumbassen kann, das ist natürlich wahr.
Man braucht selten irgendwelche Datenbanken daheim und wenn brauchen die keine großartige Dinger, die man an ihnen macht.
Was sagst du zu Big Data Tools wie Splunk? Kann ich nicht viel dazu sagen.
Also ich kenne es vom Namen her, ich weiß auch im Prinzip was es ist, also sprich, dass du damit irgendwelche Logs auswerten kannst, aber habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Hast du ein Doodle Boot als Linux Setup oder einen eigenen Rechner für Linux? Ach, weder, noch, ich kann es dir mal zeigen.
Ich mache das so mit Linux, ich gehe auf den zweiten Desktop, Data4M bei Workstation.
Ja, das ist doch nice, Fabio.
Da habe ich hier eine VM mit Linux drauf und die mache ich einfach im Fullscreen auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Und das ist im Prinzip wie eine Linux Kiste, bloß unter Windows, weil es ist halt für mich angenehmer, Linux unter Windows zu benutzen, als Windows unter Linux.
Ist einfach so, du kannst besser Linux unter Windows benutzen, als Windows unter Linux.
Dazu kommt, dass ich halt hauptsächlich Windows brauche eben für Videogedöns und fürs Spielen und das ist halt, auch wenn es unter Linux Fortschritte macht, es ist halt bei weitem noch nicht da, wo es unter Windows ist.
Ganz wichtige Frage hast du noch mit dem Friseur zu tun, klar.
Übrigens Leute, das haben ja ganz viele immer mal unter auf YouTube gefragt, es gibt mittlerweile einen MaxFPS Discord, wer das noch nicht mitgekriegt hat.
Ausrufezeichen Discord gibt es in den White Link.
Der Westersburg, nice.
Ja.
Gibt es einen Discord.
Wir haben Channels für Technikkram, Programmieren, Heimautomatisierung, irgendwelche Neuigkeiten, Looking for Group Gaming Schichten.
Der Weebspend, den kann ich jetzt nicht aufmachen, weil der ist ab 18, da spamt da Sebaro immer seine Hentai Tittenbilder.
Wir haben unseren Q-Chat, wo wir eigentlich nichts Sinnvolles mitmachen.
Ja, noch ein bisschen Discord Werbung machen.
Fuck.
Frag nicht mich, frag den Sebaro.
Erfasst du da nichts? Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Ich kann den Channel jetzt nicht aufmachen, das geht nicht.
Ja, 10.000 Views, ich bin begeistert, dass das Video instant 10.000 Views kriegt, ich meine es hat freigeschaltet, 15 Uhr.
Damn.
10 Jahre, das stimmt überhaupt nicht, dass ich ja 10 Jahre ein Video mache.
Fake News, das sind bloß 8 Monate her, dass ich ein Video gemacht habe.
Wie sie sich alle feiern.
Sieht aus wie mit Maus erspielt, ich weiß nicht vor was du sprichst.
Easy.
Das ist nicht normal.
Also ich musste, ich meine ich hab ja meine PS3 eingeschaltet.
Seit, keine Ahnung, 2 Jahren oder so.
Seit 2 Jahren hatte ich die PS3 nicht mehr an.
Und ich hab ne Stunde geupdatet, ne Stunde.
Bis das Ding funktioniert hat.
Und dann konnte ich die Modern Warfare Alpha noch nicht mehr runterladen.
Nicht PS3, PS4.
Die PS3, wo hab ich die überhaupt? Wo hab ich meine PS3?
Keine Ahnung, ich seh sie nicht.
Also ich hab hier bloß Switch, Wii U, PS4, Xbox 360 und Xbox One.
Da auf so nem Stapel neben mir stehen.
Eigentlich übelst teurer Schrottstapel, weil ich verwende nix davon.
Bin ja mal gespannt.
Wenn neue, wenn die neuen Konsolen rauskommen.
Xbox, Scarlett.
Gibt's da schon Neuigkeiten jetzt zu?
Alles, was wir wissen.
Ja gut, wir wissen, dass wir nix wissen.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt, wenn die neue Konsolengeneration rauskommt.
Ich denke mal, das wird diesmal ein größerer Sprung werden, wie bei der PS4 und bei der Xbox One.
Ich mein, der Sprung auf die Xbox One und die PS4 waren im Vergleich zu der alten Konsolengeneration jetzt nicht irgendwie so schlecht.
Also die sind schon deutlich schneller als die alte Konsolengeneration.
Aber jetzt nicht so extrem, wie es immer bei Konsolengenerationwechsel bisher war.
Und vor allem nicht im Verhältnis zu dem, was ein PC gebracht hat.
Ich war immer so überlegt, als die 360 rausgekommen ist.
Das Ding, das war so krass.
Da konnten damals fast schon kaum aktuelle PCs mithalten.
Und ich glaube, dass es diesmal nicht so sein wird, dass ein aktueller PC mit ordentlichen Grafikern nicht mithalten kann.
Aber ich glaube, der Sprung wird wieder größer und es wird dazu führen, dass die Spielehersteller wahrscheinlich mal mit ein bisschen ihre Systemanforderungen hochschrauben können.
Ich hoffe es ja, ich hoffe es ja.
Ich brauche mal wieder eine neue Grafikkarte.
Ich habe jetzt seit was, wie lange, drei Jahren oder so eine 1080 Ti?
Wann kam die raus? 2017, seit zweieinhalb Jahren habe ich die gleiche Grafikkarte.
Und es ist halt easy. Kein Ding. Geht alles, funktioniert alles richtig gut.
Und wenn eine neue Konsolengeneration rauskommt und die Anforderungen steigen, dann kaufe ich mal eine neue.
Oder ich mache bis dahin schon wieder so viele YouTube-Videos, dass ich bei Nvidia nerven kann.
Also ich tippe drauf, dass PS4 und Xbox Scarlet Ende 2020 kommen.
Es gab ja Gerüchte für März 2020, aber das halte ich für ausgeschlossen, wenn man jetzt noch nichts dazu gehört hat.
Ich meine Nvidia ist jenseits, die schweben in anderen Sphären im Kopf, was ihre Grafikkartenpreise aktuell angeht.
Wisst ihr was meine erste richtige Standalone Grafikkarte war und was sie gekostet hat?
Und das war damals vom Highend des Highends, was ich damals gekauft habe.
Die Grafikkarte war hier eine, das Ding, das war eine TNT 1 Karte, die war auch richtig, so sah die aus.
So sah das Ding aus, passiv gekühlt und wurde übertrieben warm.
Und ich glaube, die hat damals gekostet 250 Euro.
Ich weiß nicht, das war aber anteilmäßig ein Witz im Vergleich zu dem, was heute eine Highend Karte kostet.
Mittlerweile können Grafikkarten auch mehr, da ist auch mehr drauf, ich kann es schon nachvollziehen, dass es vom Anteil her teurer geworden ist.
So extrem teuer, was kostet eine 2080 TI 800 Euro, 700 Euro, 1200 Euro, das ist doch nicht normal.
1200 Euro für eine Grafikkarte, ich komme jetzt ernsthaft, die 1080 TI hat wenigstens 400 Euro weniger gekostet.
Das ist doch echt nicht mehr normal, das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein.
Da muss jetzt erstmal wieder AMD kommen, da muss jetzt einfach mal wieder AMD kommen, so ein bisschen wie bei Intel CPUs.
Da müsste, oder ich hoffe es mal zumindest, dass AMD jetzt mal wieder anrückt und mal ein paar konkurrenzfähige Grafikkarten zeigt.
Bei Intel CPUs bzw. bei CPUs hat es ja gut funktioniert.
Wenn ich mir jetzt einen Rechner bauen würde, also im Allgemeinen genommen, ich hätte nichts an Hardware hier daheim.
Und ich würde mir jetzt einen Rechner bauen, dann würde ich einen aktuellen Ryzen CPU nehmen.
Und bei Grafikkarten bin ich mir nicht sicher, also wenn ich wirklich nichts da hätte, also auch keine 1080 TI und wenn ich nichts da hätte
und mir einen ganz neuen Rechner kaufen würde, eventuell würde ich dann in den sauren Apfel beißen
und mir eine 1080 TI holen, eine 2080 TI.
Aber in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass ich einen sau schnellen CPU habe und eine sau schnellen Grafikkarte,
dann kaufe ich mir gar keinen neuen Rechner.
Aber bei CPUs würde AMD gewinnen aktuell, keine Frage.
Ich hatte ja kurz überlegt, ob ich mir für Streamen einen Ryzen Rechner bauen soll, aber wozu?
Ich habe ja noch einen anderen hier neben mir stehen, auch mit einer 4K, noch ein Intel CPU reicht ja auch dicke.
Max, warum sind die so teuer? Ich würde mir die kaufen.
Moment, das eine hat ja nicht unbedingt direkt was mit dem anderen zu tun.
Ich finde es kacke und eigentlich unverhältnismäßig teuer, aber ich will die schnellste Grafikkarte haben.
Vor allem weil es geht.
Ich meine mir ist auch klar, dass es im Endeffekt sich deswegen lohnt für Nvidia.
Aber es hat ja im Prinzip keinen Sinn, was willst du machen?
Solange AMD da nichts nachlegt, was da Konkurrenz machen kann, kann halt Nvidia auch da drehen was sie wollen.
Und ganz ehrlich, ob RTX on ist oder off ist, juckt mich persönlich überhaupt nicht.
Ich meine es gibt ein paar ganz coole Sachen.
Habt ihr Dings gesehen?
Quake 2 Raytracing.
Sieht schon cool aus.
Ich meine es ist Quake 2.
Ne.
Das da.
Das da ja.
Ich meine es ist Quake 2.
Mehr Balken hätte man da jetzt nicht drumherum machen können, oder?
Mehr Balken gehen nicht.
Ultra-Wide-Screen.
Minecraft Worldwide is also auch nice.
Das hat schon ein paar Sachen, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich bin ja eh jemand,
der nach Möglichkeit die schnellste Grafikkarte kauft und dann seine Spiele auf Low Details spielt.
Ist eigentlich beknackt, aber so bin ich halt, so mache ich das halt.
Ich will maximale FPS.
Kein Fun intended jetzt.
Ich will maximal FPS und möglichst wenig Bullshit auf dem Bildschirm.
Deswegen stelle ich alle Multiplayer-Games auf niedrige Details.
Auf niedrige Details und viel FPS.
Ich muss umstellen auf IRL.
Stimmt, hast recht.
Ja, komm.
Wollt jetzt mal nicht pipslicher sein als der Papst hier.
Rage-Racing in Excel.
Lol, Alter.
Lolwe.
Ne.
Wub-Lol.
Warum?
Hahaha, ist ja witzig.
Rage-Racing in Excel, jawoll.
Gut, ich sag's ja immer wieder in Streams.
Excel ist die Programmiersprache der Leute, die nicht programmieren können.
Ups.
Kostenlose Beigabe.
Kostenlos.
1049 Euro.
Kostenlose Beilage.
Was gibt es denn als kostenlose Beilage?
Nichts, was man braucht.
Spielst du noch ein bisschen Kot?
Ich hab schon zweieinhalb Stunden, das reicht mir.
Ist die 5700 XT eigentlich gut?
Ich kann's dir nicht sagen.
Ich glaub, der Felix hatte eine und da hat die sich mit einem Kasten Kühler geschrottet.
Und der Kasten, die haben die aber ersetzt.
Die Luft der Hersteller.
Die Wasserkühlungshersteller.
Weil der Kühler war defekt.
Ja, Tbilius, ich find's auch zu teuer.
Ich würde eher sagen, diese ganze Rage-Racing-Geschichte, das sieht gut aus.
Ich glaube auch, dass es erhalten bleiben wird.
Ja, ich glaub nicht, dass jedes Game irgendwie Rage-Racing hat.
Das ist halt performance-mäßig jetzt auch nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Aber ich würde sagen, die nächste Generation ist dann vielleicht eher das, wo ich einsteigen würde.
Hast du noch Kontakt zum Friseur? Klar.
Der Sebaro kennt die ganzen Chat-Commands.
Die sollen immer Wub-S freischalten als E-Mode.
Ich will Wub-S haben.
Wub-Lul haben wir schon, Wub-S gibt's nicht.
Sauerei, warum gibt's kein Wub-S?
Na gut, wahrscheinlich weil Twitch Deutschland im Wochenende ist, würde ich mal vermuten.
Dazu braucht man jetzt nicht sonderlich high IQ, um da drauf zu kommen.
Danke für die Follower, die gerade reingekommen sind.
Ja, okay, 22.10 Leute.
Also, ein nicer Stream heute gewesen.
Streamt er an der Serial noch, da können wir ihn hausten.
Ich werd jetzt ins Bett.
Oder, mal gucken.
Da ist auch noch das Serial am Start.
Nope.
Können wir mal hausten.
Kontrolliert Twitch.de die E-Modes von DE-Streamern, weil wahrscheinlich.
Sie im Urlaub.
Oder im Wochenende.
Nope, keiner da zum Hausten.
Also, nicer Stream gewesen, Leute.
Das war's für heute.
Danke für die Follower, die gerade reingekommen sind.